définir le rôle et les actions de la
police de sécurité du quotidien c'était
l'objectif de cette concertation une
cinquantaine de policiers gendarmes et
élus locaux ont été invités tous les
acteurs quels qu'ils soient ont souvent
insisté sur
la bonne relation la bonne compréhension
des heures et des autres et le bon
travail en commun et la bonne
coopération c'est évidemment une base
sur lequel on peut bâtir pas mal de
choses des groupes de travail et des
changes organisées sur huit réunions la
dernière avait lu à la préfecture de
versailles le 6 décembre l'occasion de
faire le point sur les idées évoquées il
ya des demandes d'accroissement des
compétences de la police municipale en
terme de contraventions possible un
terme de
deux recours judiciaires possibles et
puis aussi n'oublions pas les moyens
nécessaires pour avoir une police et de
gendarmerie et plus efficace ça passe
aussi c'est vrai par les moyens accrus
notamment dans les commissariats les
tablettes tactiles
une police connecter une police mieux
équiper une police sur mesure selon le
ministre de l'intérieur gérard collomb
dont les contours restent encore floues
le compte rendu de ces réunions il sera
adressé le 15 décembre les premières
expérimentations de cette nouvelle
police devrait se faire dès janvier 2018